in the last video we used a set of
parametric equations to describe the
position of a car as it fell off of a
cliff and the equations were x
as a function of t was and i'll write
that x as a function of t was equal to
10 i believe i did this a couple of
hours ago so i think that's what i said
10 plus 5t
and y as a function of t
was equal to 50
minus 5
t squared and the graph looks something
like this let me redraw it never hurts
that was the y-axis
that's the x-axis
and we saw that at t equals 0 and we
could
try t equal 0 here and we'll get the
point 10 comma 50. so the point 10 comma
50 was right there that was at t
equal to zero and then we plotted a few
points in the last video i think t
equals one was there t equals two was
like
there and t equal three looks something
like that and this was the path of
of the
of the actual car is it as it hurl
hurdled to the ground
but this parametric equation actually
doesn't just describe this part of the
of the curve it describes a a curve that
goes in in both directions forever so it
describes
a curve that does something like this if
you actually plot t equals minus 1 what
do you get here t equals minus 1 you get
minus 5 so 10 minus 5 is 5. if you put a
minus 1 here you get this becomes a plus
1. so minus one so you get 545 so you
get that point right there and if you
did minus two you're going to get a
point that looks something like that and
minus three you're going to get points
something like that so the whole curve
described by this parametric equation
will look something like this let me do
it in a different color
it looks something like this
and so and the direction as x increases
as sorry as t increases looks like this
right this is t is equal to minus 3
minus 2 minus 1 0
1 2 and so forth and so on so in the
last example our path was actually just
a subset of the path described by this
parametric equation and i'm saying all
of this because sometimes it's useful to
just bound your parametric equation say
this is the path only for certain values
of t in our example it was when we leave
this point which is at t equals zero all
the way to when we hit the ground so if
we want to know those boundaries well we
know the first boundary is t equals zero
so this in the last example
for when we actually talked about a car
careening off of a cliff it was between
zero so t is greater than or equal to 0
and then we have to figure out what t
what t value makes us hit the ground or
when does y equal 0 because when y
equals 0 y is our altitude so when y
equals 0 we've hit the ground so if we
say what t value makes y equals 0. we
just say 0 equals 50 minus 5t squared so
let's do that
0
is equal to 50
minus 5 t squared i just took this and
set y equal to 0 because that's when
we're going to be hitting the floor
add 5t squared to both sides you get 5t
squared is equal to 50
divide both sides by 5 t squared is
equal to 10
t is equal to
the square root of 3. and you can
actually say plus or minus square root
of three because this is we hit the
ground right at t is equal to square
root of oh sorry square t is equal to
square root of ten
t is equal to square root of ten my
brain did three because i immediately
said oh square root of 10 that's 3 point
something something so this is square t
equals square root of 10 which is
approximately equal to 3.2 i don't know
ones i don't know what it is i should
probably
take get my calculator going but that's
not important for this and if we
actually took the positive and negative
square root this would be
t
is equal to the negative
square root of 10.
out here there's a negative sign right
there and if you could go backwards in
time you would have hit kind of hit the
ground there but it remember in our
example we weren't going backwards in
time if we went backwards in time at t
minus one we were actually on a plateau
and then there would have been a
different set of parametric equations
that would have described the car when
it was when it was just driving on the
plateau so if we really want to describe
the path of the car we should have
bounded it set and said that between
time is equal to 0 and time
being less than the square root of 10
this would have been our parametric
equations fair enough
now the next thing that's interesting is
you know we took these parametric
equations and we generalized it and we
just said what it would look like if we
didn't bound it if this wasn't the case
then the parametric equation would just
keep going like that and it would have
this kind of direction
right it would move in in that direction
but can we express the set of parametric
equation is just a a normal
a normal equation where y is expressed
as a function of x or x is expressed as
a function of y
and
let's try
so the easiest thing to do is just let's
just rewrite them
just so we clean up our board so if you
have x is equal to 10 plus 5t
and y is equal to
50
minus 5t squared
if we want to write this system as just
a
an equation with just y and x what we
can do is we can just solve
for t in terms of either x or y and then
substitute back into the other equation
so the easier one to solve is this top
equation because it's a linear equation
this is a little more complicated we'll
have you know t is equal to a square
root of y and it becomes a lot more
complicated so let's just use this
so if we want to solve for t let's
subtract 10 from both sides you get
x
minus 10 is equal to 5t
divide both sides by 5 you get x over 5
minus 2 right 10 divided by 5 is equal
to t
and now we can take this and substitute
it this is t right so we can take this
and substitute it back here for t
because we say this is equal to t
so our equation becomes
y is equal to 50
minus 5 times x
minus
x over 5 minus 2
squared and let's simplify this so this
is equal to
let's switch colors
50 minus 5 times this is x squared over
25
minus i see two fifths so it's four
fifths
x
plus four
and then if you multiply then this is a
y out here so you get y is equal to 50
and let's see minus five times see minus
five over 25 is minus one fifth so minus
x squared over five minus five times
minus four fifths that's
plus 4
x and then minus 5 times 4 is minus 20.
we're almost there we can add the 50 to
the negative 20 and we get
we get y that's too dark y
is equal to
minus x squared over five plus four x
plus thirty and we're done we just i
guess we could say simplified this set
of parametric equations
to
this one equation where y is a function
of x and so you might be saying sal why
didn't we just always have it this way
this is so much more simple and we can
just graph this and you know how to deal
with it and it's just one equation with
just y and x we don't have this third
variable t
and that might be okay if you just want
to know the shape of the path so if you
took this equation and if i told you to
graph it you would indeed get a parabola
kind of a downward opening parabola that
looks something like that but when you
go from these two equations to this one
equation you lose information if i told
you that this describes the path of an
object some object it doesn't have to be
the car we've we've progressed beyond
that it describes the path of some
object just with this equation alone
you don't know
if the object is
is the object going this way is it going
like that or is the object going in the
other direction like our car did is the
object going that way we don't know
because we don't know how it moves
according to time
likewise if i told you this was the this
was the path of the object and then i
asked you where is the object after five
seconds
you don't know because this just tells
you what the shape where x is relative
to y or where y is relative to x it
doesn't tell you where you are after
five seconds so we've lost all of that
information we've lost information that
this is t equals zero this is t equals
one this is t equals two this is t
equals three this is t equals the square
root of ten and that's why parametric
equations are useful but anyway i wanted
to do this example mainly to show you
that you can express the same shape this
way and also to show you how to express
a parametric equation in terms of a you
know just a y and an x but also for you
to appreciate that the parametric
equation is useful and that you it does
contain information that this just
single equation won't contain anyway see
in the next video